we have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 to David P..
This voicemail caller asks the question I
asked on Twitter a few days ago, what if the
armed corona virus protesters were groups
of black people?
Would it be different how they were handled?
Take a listen to the voice mail question.
Hi, David.
My question is, when protesters are blocking
our entrances, harassing nurses and bringing
rifles on state capitol grounds.
Where are the police?
Right.
If black people or any other group did the
same exact same carrying guns, the police
would be there in riot gear.
Arresting people, but if you carry an American
flag in your flight, you can walk any place
you want with a rifle.
That's my question.
Thanks.
Yeah, I am presenting the question without
comment.
Check out my tweet about it.
See what the reactions were.
And I want to hear from you.
What if, indeed, the lion's share of the lockdown,
protesters showing up with long guns?
And I think some of them even like bulletproof
vests.
What if they were mostly black folks?
How would this this be covered in media?
How would police react?
Let me know what you think.
We have a fantastic bonus show today.
We will talk about risks of additional starvation
as a result of the Corona's about coronavirus
pandemic on the bonus show and much more.
Get instant access by signing up at join PACOM
or becoming a patron at Patriot dot com slash
David Pakman.